we need a lot of study including the
study in these head of challenges
because of
lack of equipment scientists cannot
access
that vision so i need a
team to develop that system
as quick as possible provide the tools
to the scientists let them make a
competitive survey of all the chinese
then understand that what echo
ecosystems
if we can use this kind of philosophy
to replace the currently materials the
philosophy
mainly of the social problems can be
automated
solved or disappeared
someone's opinion may contradict yours
where's my friend alan
it's all about your perspective who are
we and what is the nature of this
[Music]
reality
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host alan sakyan
we are on site at the beautiful west
lake university
in hangzhou china we are now going to be
talking about
deep sea technology we have dr
huichong suede joining us on the show
hello
thank you so much for coming on our show
we really appreciate it
yeah i'm so excited for this for those
who don't know which one's background
he's professor npi at pi at westlake
university researching
deep sea technology to provide research
tools to scientists
to understand and explore our oceans and
you can find the links in the bio below
which let's start things off with one of
our favorite questions we like asking
our guests
yeah what are your thoughts on the
general direction of our world
okay and in the last
200 years our science and
technology developed very fast and it
has
changed dramatically to our
everyday life and initially people
always think
science and technology can bring the
happiness
to our human beings but as
the society develops go on
for my own observation
with a steer like there are a lot of
people
still devoting high pressure and didn't
feel so happy and the gap between
each country poor country rich
religions foreign country
or different people then even rich
people
have some of the problems they face
poor people also have some problems they
face
and so basically i find the
now i'm question i have the question
whether science
can dairy bring the happiness
to our human beings can nearly solve
the problems the development problems
was disputed between different countries
different nations or different
religions and i i find
that science actually is limited
and maybe the fundamental reason
or the cause is a philosophy
can we find the sort of
a a way of you know of the common
value of human beings and actually what
are our human beings what's the perfect
direction for a world to be a how to
assess
to be a success of a human being or
something
and quite a lot of questions
cannot have not been addressed
in science and this is related to the
philosophical questions or something at
the moment
it is things that people are more
favorite on
science and technology ignore what
people
quite a lot of people think philosophy
is not important
so from my own point of view of
observation
our world or our human beings we
are all lost the right direction
we are maybe good on the long directions
or something
and at the moment the person
who like can
uh destroy the earth more and more
people have the power
to destroy it then other people i just
live under the risk of this
individual person if they lost their
temper
they are fighting each other maybe
suddenly it affected
other ordinary people something
so how to solve such kind of
issue it is maybe more
important than just further developing
the science and technology
so if we look back at when we
first discovered fire yeah
we can use the fire to
help us cook food we can use fire to
burn
villages so immediately the philosopher
was needed
you could just say please cook just food
don't burn the villages with this
and so now fast forward yeah
millions years later to
modern day civilization yeah and
we have exponential technologies nuclear
bombs biotechnologies
nuclear neuro technologies artificial
intelligences
we need philosophers at
google facebook apple linkedin
uh amazon uh tencent alibaba baidu
yeah uh all of the big companies
in the world need big staffs of
philosophers
ethicists moral scientists
and this can ensure that maybe
instead of making technology that helps
wealthy people become wealthier yeah
which we'll talk about in the show
that you can use some of these great
deep-sea
technologies to pillage the oceans and
take the for myself the resources or we
can use them to advance
science and understand ourselves and our
oceans um
better and and share the benefits yeah
with the world so
i love your focus on this and and
i will return to this to this topic
again
um let's talk about your journey how did
you as a
child get interested in science and
okay the oceans yeah great that's a
great question
and as a matter of fact when i was a boy
so i'd say after junior high school we
will go to the farmers
we never have the chance to go to
university or something
so during that time we no hope
to be like the well educated and then
near the last or end of my junior high
school
only half a year left then the cultural
revolution
stopped and our country go to
like a new period started to have
equity there's a entrance examination
who can go to the high school and then
go to university
so given me only half a year i have seen
the chance
that is the first time i started
to have my dream and i plan three steps
first to be go to the
high middle high school in our county
then second step go to university to be
a university student
and then finally to be a scientist so
during that time
the my inflation scientist is the
most is the the the
greatest person i can admire or
something
and then i study hard and i step by step
went to the middle good middle high
school
and went to the university actually to
the qinghuang nursery one of the best
university china
in the united time then i spent some
time
to read the philosophy read the history
and then actually during that period
after
thinking what actually the society from
observation or something
i gradually set up my uh
solution reading solution thinking and
actually i found
my idol or the person i actually
admired mr lee sotong
i taken him as a life master
so what i wanted to have a life
is a life like him so in that case
scientist is not my final target i
wanted to be a person
like him to to be a useful person
to the society to the people and i do
not
care what the profession i i was asked
to do something his
personality basically two categories one
is very kind to the societal people
only do good things to the people second
is to everything he if he wanted to to
be the
very best or to be the perfect person
so one is very clear to everything to be
very careful
to do it best second you know
i only do those things that would be
benefited to the society to the people
not myself so that's actually the two
fundamental qualities and nowadays
from my observation i think like
scientists
may be only paired to one aspect i
wanted to be the best
to science or technology to another care
how to use your result or something
if you paid to me either by a politician
or by a
rich person or something and then i
received the payment i do the
scientific development but i think in
that case
advanced the scientific tools could be
misused
and for my admiration when something
wanted to be a scientist like einstein
for something
if i found this guy
maybe misuse my research product
i should refuse yeah even customer life
i do not want to be something so
basically
like such kind of person is the one i
admire rather than pure i
did you i can solve the technical
problem i don't care
any other scenes or something yeah yeah
yeah
so this is really cool that
if we have a very deep
ethical grounding in our lives that we
can
really be vigilant with
what we accept as um
as friends as
money as um all different types of um
of what is being added to our lives we
can basically
have a filter and say that i will not
accept
the what i'm what what value what
scientific advancement i'm making into
the world if you're gonna use it
inappropriately to cause violence
yeah um i i like that a lot and
it's really interesting how even in your
youngest years you began
caring a lot about that and it's very
evident that it's
here with you um now also
i think that's actually really important
for young people that
if uh if we can have them
at younger ages care more about
philosophy and ethics and these types of
leaders then later in life it becomes
without a question these types of
i like that a lot so what about um
when you did mechanics and then you did
structural reliability
at the university of bristol in the
united kingdom um
what were you studying about yeah yeah
the technology okay so
that's because it's my that attitude
i actually really flexible to the
environment i would say that i was
to be chosen china's chief scientific
center
to be the place i started my master's
degree
and but lucky enough
i started i got the chance
to be sent to uk for starter phd
starting my phd but that scholarship was
awarded by british council basically
there
could can respect that you are select
or for like the total navy architecture
or something but
they can also allocate you to another
university or another
so they allocated me to that imperial
college
in the civil engineering department so
in that case
okay i have to start getting my phd
in the civil engineering systems and
after that of course i spent
18 months in impercology then
transferred to bristol finished my phd
in civil engineering so that subject at
that time first set a theory was
something quite a new
mathematics ideally i chose that subject
but after that i wanted to get
some experience and post the documentary
search my supervisor
do not have the project funding to
support
my continued research so i find
another advancement to work
on composite materials the aerospace
engineering
so i just the problem to speak to the
professor
your project i can do it because my
previous background is sodium mechanics
so
after that i actually did three years
posted a doctoral research in department
of department of aerospace engineering
but so during that period okay i i did a
lot of work on composite materials
or something therefore according to my
own
preference i worked in that area
it's much better but i had the agreement
with the chinese scientific resource
center this is there giving me the
chance
to study the uk i have the
responsibility
to return back to that institute to work
for them
so after three years post-doctorate
i went back to a chinese ship scientific
center
to start to start my research as an
architect
uh you're still now an adjunct professor
at shanghai ocean university you started
there in 2013 though
and um you were doing project lead in
the research and development of hadal
science
and technology movable laboratory yeah
now we need to talk about the huddle
trenches because
these are trenches that are deeper than
6 000 meters yeah
they're pitch dark there's no light and
they're kind of the last unexplored
frontier
on earth yeah so why are you so
fascinated with that zone and what were
you doing at shanghai ocean university
and still doing that yeah that's a a
good question
the first is that i
cheated myself or regarding myself i was
sought out for a topologist scientists
i should do all these challenging tasks
of
launcher work and
then what do you find that for the
journal
we reached 7000 meters but at
the same time james cameron developed
around
11 000 meters many submissive so for our
technology
uh field flying seven thousand minutes
to eleven sunday
is certain direction that what i wanted
to do
secondly develop this submission
also very useful for the society with
human beings
because deep head of changes is at least
explored by our human beings we still
don't
know actually how deep is the challenge
deep
whether there is a fish or not in these
deep trenches
there are a lot of curious questions we
don't know
and also maybe some were
10 years 20 years later our human beings
were exploited the ocean resources
but the water speed in what method
we explore this explorer exploit
these ocean resources we are not
destroying our
ecosystem or something we need a lot of
study
including the study in these head of
challenges
because of lack of equipment scientists
cannot
access that legion so
i need a team to develop that
system as quick as possible provide the
tours
to the scientists let them make a
competitive survey of
all the chinese then understand that
what ecosystems then you can assess
such that in our china south china sea
if
we are decided to exploit
certain type of resources
what's the consequence what's the effect
will affect
this ecosystem something we can answer
this
question where we are not bringing such
as a very bad
consequence to the society or something
so i think that
what one is to demonstrate
my idea like any kind of team i can lead
i know the management method already
and to attack this challenge technical
problems
second the tools i developed
is useful for the ocean scientists they
can use that
to do some useful work to help the
society
so that's actually the motivation so
like if you manage the resources
and the the people and processes in
effective ways you can get more science
done
effectively and then also i like how you
focus
on being able to take the scientific
advancements that you achieve in the
field
it requires really good engineering
skills too you have to engineer the
submersibles to be robust
and then you take that tool and
democratize it to scientists around the
world
so that they can research the haddle
zones
and understand life on this planet more
deeply
i like that that process for you and so
okay so now
let's talk about these um these
differences
in um in our unexplored oceans and how
we're
um exploring them so you guys have about
14 people in the lab here at westlake
university that's right
and you're there's so let's break this
down so there's a couple things let's
start with this
there's the human occupied vehicles yeah
okay so that's hovs then there's
uh unmanned underwater vehicles
and under unmanned underwater vehicles
there's a uvs which are
autonomous underwater vehicles and rovs
which are remotely operated
under water vehicles so that still
requires a human but behind the
computer and so what are
the differences between these i mean
they do all different types of missions
um we were talking about um remus which
goes and
and does the um the um
the mind sweeping so it's finding all of
the old
uh minds from the wars and and
destroying those
which it can actually terminate and
discover and terminate underwater mines
in one square mile and 16 hours whereas
uh it used this is only a three foot
long robot
um which it used to take teams of divers
and it used to be less safe and blah
blah blah
but um we also do things like map
submerged wrecks rocks
we do things like just uh scan
our ocean floors look for samples
yeah and take them back so let's talk
about the different
vehicles submersibles how you design
them and what they're doing yeah
okay so basically yeah you're right
mend unmanned two types unmanned
can be divided into rv auv
so basically auv it means without
any cable so you can to do a wide area
survey
so the basic way is the lights and the
videos
cameras so just record of this
the the wider area information and if
you want to
do some focus the work to take a sample
or something
then you use the remotely operated
rv rv has a long cable to
transmit a power to the submissive
so basically have a long unlimited
use of the power or something what is
the point because of this cable
it is harder to move wider area so it
can be
fostered in a particular site asansi and
then you
or demoted operate it as a manipulator
to get to the sample or something
but the cable is there so it doesn't get
lost
unless the cable is broken so cable is
broken
because when you are doing the cover
they were during operation you have got
the sun
the southern city heaven could be lost
so we are a lot of always also getting
lost
they will be
expected situation happened then changed
the
program they go to other directions then
far away from your ship
you couldn't deceive any signal flying
it it will last
so basically the unmeter submersible has
a high
disk to be lost yes then also the main
submissive
your main inside you can do the very
define the work
focus i can focus from window operate my
manipulator or something yes
and then they can consider 3d uh
like the ceiling or something so you can
wider i can work it in a wide area
i've done this work done don't let it
work
so but you need oxygen food yeah
yeah exactly so basically like the three
different type of submariner each has
disadvantages
disadvantages so basically a good
set of tool is a combination
of a system if that work
can be done use aov that's the cheapest
use aov if that work can be done use roy
okay use the rv if that worker needed to
be defined the worker needed to be used
huv then you send the hov down
and maybe in the evening you use your
aov ov
in the day you also put your main
supplements there
and also there can work collectively
like the auv go aligned and
also you show how the how we how the
actual we are doing working or something
so this combination of tools that would
be
very ideal look at all the
comprehensive information for the
scientists
you know where which place you
did the sampling how do you get the
sampling or something
because otherwise if you use only many
supplements we are doing something
we know the code of others how do you do
the sampling which actually is a
location where nearby
uh a topography or something yeah so
that's that's why the main idea why i
had this
called a comprehensive medication system
it's a combination of
unmanned submensable mental submersible
and now
for the amp and the submersible okay
they started
in the what's called the new concept
hybrid
unmanned submission so one submissive
you can
either convert it as a aov or
operate it as a rov so chatted in the
ship
this time i use a cable this that time i
have this other cable
it's an auv so one submission has two
modes of
yes yes that's a very economic
the human can maybe remotely operate it
when
you need a very precise exact movement
or
resources to grab yeah and but for
these submersibles you're still working
on the batteries
the battery can only last let's say 10
hours or 12 hours
limited time and in the deepest
part such if you wanted to
catch the fish or record the behavioral
fish
you don't know how long fish will come
or something
so if you wanted to stay in the button
for a longer time
then land is the cheapest means
so that is why we also developed some
such a
very economic really cheap means lenders
like this
camera system we threw into the button
we can work
there for one week yes one month
even a year that's no problem
settle down record the long time so if
you want equipment
to to be installed on the save button
for a longer period then land
is the cheapest that means yes yeah so
that is why as you see
my comprehensive system design design is
have several 11 000 meter lenders
one unmanned hybrid unmanned
submission called the arv autonomous and
the motor operated
vehicle and one hov and then spread
one specific ship for this
equipment yes to be operated yes yes
the landers are so interesting too
because
they have uh glass spheres for buoyancy
yeah
and then you can drop them down 11
000 meters and then they have different
like you said you can add video cameras
you can add sampling ability so i can
sample from the floor um
so we can conduct science for months or
years
at a time with these landers you can
actually resurface them afterward
yeah um instead of these limitations
with the battery power
exactly which i thought which i think is
a really interesting part of what you're
talking about
now um what would we
want to be finding like what's the
no what's the top let's say three
reasons
yeah that we you know the oceans i think
what is it ninety-five percent
unexplored
you conducted yeah and seventy percent
of our planet is oceans
and ninety-five percent unexplored yeah
and it's and
uh below how many meters there's no
light
well basically about
500 meters deeper there's
no sunlight no sunlight once you go 500
meters deep yeah
and the deepest is mariana trench yeah
which
is 11 000 meters yep okay
so what why why and this is
you know next to usually next to the
land the continents
yeah is a little bit the shelf the sea
shelf
exactly and then it goes down the deeper
yeah so we can find different things
on the sea shelf um then on the very
eleven
thousand so one thousand three thousand
meter different than
eleven thousand yeah yeah so why
what do we send the submersibles
to find what are the top three things we
send to find okay
um basically uh i'm not a
uh scientist like to the ocean uh
science you're the technologist the
landers and the yeah our human beings
capabilities as less than 600 meters
for the ocean basically we got some
tours
to do the exploration of sunset
scientifically switching means
but below the 6000 meters there is
very few or little equipment
for that the what's called united states
you developed the netherlands unmanned
submarines
and then successfully in 2008 and
it lost in 2014.
in japan there is a keiko rv
directed in 1995 and getting lost
in three and james camilo
developed a 11 000 meter meant
submersible
but that one only for type one's
exploration was just taking the
like guinness record or something not
very useful for the scientists
and so scientists
still don't at the moment don't have
access to us to the head of trenches
so this more or less gave us
china a chance you know to be the leader
in that area to develop or make some
contributions
to that area so that is
my wish or hope
so i wanted our for personality
i found there is a gap there if i can
provide a population of maintenance of
amazon
the first operation of mental supplement
for the world
scientists yeah that would be a big
personal achievement
yeah so that is my main motivation
five or six years ago i studied and then
i work on that yeah and we yes you're a
tool builder
for deep sea technology but just give us
an idea like
what would the landers be finding or
what would the
submersibles be looking for okay top
couple things
yeah yeah basically there are a lot of
scenes one is like
you get the uh first basically the
the survey of the c pattern say
geography image and
the the map or resource distribution or
anything
second you get some somebody in
particular taking the ocean with the sea
water
yes and then sediment yes the button
what kind of structure what kind of
the sky serving then sampling
somebody of anything you start started
the occasion
and say currently one of the focus
with our plastic pollution has been
affected to the trench
yeah so the the like the creatures in
the church
whether they are polluted by this
plastic
and it is now confirmed even the
amphipods in the marine chinese yeah
inside the stomach and there is a
plastic bag it is
already been confirmed so basically
like the whole severe the situation and
also
you you can study the impact of like the
atomic nuclear waste if you put it
inside
the cabin and also you could
rescue and recovery like the lust of the
mhe37 yellow or something
you need a lot of some measurements to
make the soviet
uh where the airplane clash
if you also for the rescue of the
little mexico you know oil
platform accident or something you need
a lot of
equipment and some messages for rescue
so i think that uh then use archaeology
or tortoise or anything so actually
it also finds a lost bones
in the ocean or you you get a cheater uh
yeah
dispose of this uh
the the the the the bombs
in the ocean like the left for the
second world war or something
so there are plenty of work can be done
by these
submersibles and our human beings are
lacking of this kind of
tools because they are not easy to be
developed cost
quite a lot technology really challenge
only a few people
can do it so so that that's actually
quite really useful yeah yeah
wow so we need to sit we need to survey
first our entire ocean floor
yeah um with high quality video
and just geographical geological
research we need to sample the different
sediments the different uh ocean
life as well down there to catalog it
maybe there's unique things like
gfp yeah came from the jellyfish
and so maybe there's other unique
aspects of biology
yeah that we can use in understanding
neuroscience
or the cell in general so
okay so we need to do that and then we
have this um
i like how you also said there's like um
there's
we can deploy the different technologies
uh like a suite like a big suite of
deployments so
it's not only the landers but it's the
landers and it's the
autonomous ones and the human-operated
ones and the robotic ones all this type
of stuff
and then also there's there's wrecks
that need to be explored if we want to
understand
the archaeology the record of how humans
got here
yeah we should go look at some of the
sea floors there's interesting things
down there about
how we the micro plastics is a little
bit it's
it's a little gross we we are hopefully
evolving fast enough to realize that
we come from those oceans then we need
to stop polluting them also the um
uh somewhere in the range of 70 of all
of our
carbon sequestration is from
phytoplankton
yeah final product but also about the 50
percent of the carbon
may be located in this header transit
so all the the area is very smooth but
the carbon
content actually occupied quite a high
percentage wow opposite
it's a carbon cycle yeah cycle something
interesting so it could be
that problem it could be that these
these ocean
geo geothermal and geological events and
produce a decent amount of the the
carbon cycle
process yeah interesting understanding
the escalator mechanism
that's header transit also very
important yeah wow
so some of the the tectonic
plates we usually only study on the
continents
but when you look at the ocean floors
those
um those chances
and then the energy for accumulated in
that area
to a certain level it becomes a big
earthquake or something yeah so maybe
these places
are the first places to be detected
there where there is a big earthquake
one or
yeah so that's an ideal place for
studying as quick as well
yeah yes yes wow wow wow okay
it's so interesting okay so why don't
you um also teach us about
like um what is
um what is kind of like the
where you see this a heading like
um maybe in 50 or 100 years
let's say yeah what would be your ideal
uh way for us to go and uh
survey and uh sample
yeah uh the oceans what would be the
ideal tool or technology
okay my point of view
such as the technologies another five
years or
ten years is matured to
explore the oceans or something and if
you
spend some cost every country
get repair some something get more
submersible
to do the survey because this is a
tremendous
working load no one country
can afford to do all that and this is
benefited to all our human beings
similar as you know like the map
to the land it's a competing map
for the ocean so basically for this
if you want to have computer survey of
one transition say marine change
maybe it costs uh one year ship time or
something
it costs quite quite a lot and there are
more than 40 chances or something so if
only one you have one system one ship
maybe it takes
40 years or something similar as our
human beings
gene project if we
organized together you made your you
survey this
challenge you service that challenge we
put it together
maybe another 10 years or something so
now actually the main problem
our human being faced can we
really work together coordinate for the
same target yeah
disability difficulty i like that for
our
like deduction of the carbon dioxide we
initially had the government
but if one country blogs
and for this how to organize like the
united
nations or some organizations yes plan
more rules
to do that or something like the ocean
cleanup
project or the like the ocean mapping
project yeah yeah this type of exactly
yeah so we can make the
all the ocean transparent similar as
uh working as a load or something and
like the human genome
yeah yeah yeah yeah computer that's
right so this uh
there's an organization where someone
come to be
the data project or something open
source the oceans
for scientific open science notebook
style
you can actually research yeah like the
audio project or something yeah they
already have
some pleasure to be done but for these
header transit
we also need without that kind of
organization
this could take us 40 years or 100 years
or something
or whether we don't can finish or not
but another risk is ready for
for me to see for our human beings
is how to avoid the wars either
local or global of course that's all the
world war
because if you if there are two leaders
or three leaders
they are not happy with each other they
started fighting
and then divided it into two pies and
fighting each other so as our human
beings
actually no one can destroy ourselves
only ourselves so yeah yeah so
basically such a oh an asteroid yeah
yeah yeah so basically like as a only
our human beings like
every country respect each other there
therefore harmoniously
then they try to solve the
environmental issues any kind of issues
or something that's uh
under that condition or this science
politicalizing
then we exploit the ocean resources to
make people
live much better to improve our
situations like the all the
poor people can survive can live for
better life or something
yeah so that's my point of view that is
more important i agree then purely
technology politicalizing science
followers yes yes yes
um the importance of
our relationship to nature let's talk
about this because
um in order to avoid more
war and suffering and uh
and issues with our lack of ethics or
philosophy
yeah if we dive deeper into where we
come from
where do we come from we you go back
back back
back back back we all come from a single
source yeah and that
source is nature and
and we breathe the air we eat the food
we drink the water
of the planet of mother earth of this
beautiful planet
and it's also interconnected there is no
air that i breathe that you don't
breathe and so when we see it that way
and we connect to nature more
and if scientists especially when you
push the frontier of
knowledge this edge further and further
if you have philosophers or ethicists or
moral
scientists working with you of these big
tech companies these big governments
around the world
it's easier to collaborate and it's
easier to
remember that we come from we come
with this at the same time of evolution
so how do you see the human relationship
with
nature especially with our oceans
and how does our disconnection from that
affect the issues we have in our world
yeah
so that is basically i had a quite a lot
of
thinking about that and now what i found
is that
actually that's a collective mistake in
the
20th century yes and the materialist
philosophy dominates yes and actually
this philosophy scientifically now we
can
have a lot of questions to that this is
not very scientific
i have a lot of paradoxes about that yes
but
they didn't address like the
the relations who am i what's the
relation
i with the other people it's animal
with the nature so more or less is
separated but as a matter of fact we
should
have sort of another philosophy is this
a harmonious
system i can leave better
only if my environment is better
my environment includes other people
like
this one of the skin of my body or
something
so in that case if you cheated the whole
earth
is my body and everyone or
every life on earth is part of my body
myself or something in that case okay
can be like the really if i
well most people believe in that kind of
philosophy
then you can get harmonious okay
the with nature or something but
otherwise he said oh we are fighting for
the resources
if i kill you then all the results
belong to i become rich
i can divide so have beta or something
so in that case you know
make the people where they should i say
it really really
wanted to like the you become
well i like this can only debate it
sacrifice of others and no one can want
to be sacrificed
so they want to fight against the
survivors
so in that case like this is a very
big mistake or
this what's the actually the value
or how to assess uh good people
uh about our people or something get rid
of
this without this humans greedy
or something and it's very hard to get a
harmonious
society harmonious with people from my
philosophy there's no enemy at all enemy
was
born from your heart you regard someone
as my enemy his anime i cheated as a
friend he's my friend yes yeah so simple
as every love animal love dog
snack anything because if you kill one
kind of
species it will affect others it's a
discourse
yeah it's a cycle can be decided
butterfly effect yeah the
okay 10 million species right now on the
planet
every single one of them can be thought
of like a cell
in an organism and so there's heart
cells muscle cells bone cells
so it's very important to remember to
be very very
careful with this ecosystem that gives
us life
yeah that sustains us that is all
interconnected
now i want to talk about this too so
um this has now been said over and over
again
this idea that we must
slow down um
and it's hard because a lot of people
want to speed up
the speed up technology speed up science
it's very important
and we agree it's important to push the
science and technology
but if you do it without
long-term thinking seven generational
thinking seven generations out you risk
causing serious issues because if we do
the genetic engineering of a way of
disease
this is of course we understand this is
important yes yeah can we
also really consider what will happen
seven generations out with this process
thank you thank you thank you so much
okay for coming it's a pleasure yeah
it's been such a pleasure talking to you
thank you thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking
have more conversations with your
friends families co-workers people
online
about the things we talked about in the
episode about deep sea technology
about all of the different styles
of underwater submersibles and about
their
importance in understanding our oceans
and also about ethics and about
philosophy and about spirituality and
about nature about all the things we
talked about
regarding that as well check out the
links in the bio below
to wei chang's profiles also support the
artists the entrepreneurs
the organizations around the world that
you believe and support them and help
them grow
you can support simulation our links are
below so we continue doing cool
things like coming on site to westlake
university
for incredible interviews with leading
professors principal investigators
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we'll see
you soon
peace
okay yeah yeah thank you okay thank you
[Music]
you